How many times a week can I do a sauna also how long and 10 and what 10 I think they're it?
So you can actually do a sauna. I think you could do a sauna every day.
So
Now again, I think if you've never done a sauna and you just got a sauna, I think you have to work up to that
So like anything you could overdo it right away and you could feel really icky and so you got to just be careful in that
So but if you have a sauna and you've done it before and you like it
Then then start doing it. You could do once a day. How long?
I wouldn't go more than 30 minutes and if you're new to doing a sauna
You might only be able to do 10 minutes. Don't like I'm gonna sit in here. I'm gonna force myself to do 30 minutes
No, no, personally, you know, I have the sauna that zips up in your head sticks out. I haven't done it since last
Winter and it's about time to do it again. We're supposed to have
5 inches of snow tomorrow
So it's kind of sauna weather
But I seem to not tolerate more than 20 minutes. I gotta get on it there. Maybe it's just my
OCD
ADHD
character
But I it feels wonderful for the first 15 minutes and I kind of struggled through the last five minutes and I like out here and down in 20 minutes
Everybody's different. So don't think that there's a magic number you gotta do
30 minutes
And then what tab typically we recommend 140 I have some people that might comment. Oh, I'm do 160. I do one side
Typically, it's 140 that you start with